ich kann einfach durch die Hölle
schwimmen wie crazy ist das hallo mein
name Z meine Damen und Herren ich
versuche heute Minecraft durchzuspielen
allerdings ist Lava Wasser und Wasser
ist Lava wir haben dafür natürlich auch
schon hier den perfekten Spawn ehrlich
gesagt wir befinden uns nämlich auf
irgendeiner einsamen Insel wir können
das ganze erstmal kurz testen oh ja es
funktioniert ach du
scheiße ach du grüne neune wie soll ich
denn jetzt da rüber
kommen also okay wir müssen logisch
denken ich baue erstmal Blöcke ab
sandblöcke ja W chillig wenn ich jetzt
nicht direkt
sterb perfekt super Start bisher ich R
komplett aus wir haben hier vorne zwei
Blöcke schon mal abgebaut ich glaube das
reicht doch nicht deswegen nehme ich
jetzt mal erstmal ein paar mehr wir
haben extra auch übrigens die Texturen
so gelassen dass wir nämlich ach guck
mal drei hätten doch gereicht wir haben
extra die Texturen so gelassen
verbrennen auch Items drin ach du
kacke oh mein Gott das heißt wenn ich
mich einmal vertue und mir denk ach ja
Wasser ich springe da rein und es ist
Lava dann sind auch gleich alle meine
Items weg aber gut wir haben
dementsprechend um diese Verwirrung
einfach auch weiter mit drin zu haben
die Texturen so gelassen so dass Wasser
aussieht wie Wasser aber Lava ist und
Lava sieht auch aus wie Lava ist aber
schlussendlich Wasser das heißt ich
werde wahrscheinlich wenn ich es
vergesse der Lava versuchen auszuweichen
obwohl ich da eigentlich rein kann was
besonders gegen Ende des Videos glaube
ich ganz cool wird wenn wir in Höhlen
sind hinsichttig Diamanten und so und in
Wasser werde ich ich hoffe nicht aber
wenn ich es vergessen sollte
reinspringen und dann wird halt ziemlich
blöd von daher erstmal eine ganz kurze
timel wie ich mir meine groben Sachen
hier
[Musik]
vorbereite so Freunde ich habe mir jetzt
erstmal 28 Fichtenstämme geholt eine
Workbench gemacht und hier das
grundsätzliche standardeipment erstmal
geholt oh mein Gott ach das habe ich ja
voll
vergessen oh mein Gott oh mein Gott ich
bin so dumm ich brauch Lava also ich
brauch Wasser oh mein Gott wenn ich
jetzt sterb ne wenn ich jetzt sterbe ey
wie soll denn das werden wenn ich dann
am Ende in der Höhle
bin ja in Ordnung brenn
weiter locker easy es werden natürlich
mehr und mehr bränd kommen weil diese
ganzen Bäume hier natürlich quasi e da
vorne auch direkt an der Lava stehen es
ist zwar Wasser aber es ist ja Lava also
ich GL hab verstanden mittlerweile worum
es im heutigen Video gehen soll ich
versuche auf jeden Fall Minecraft
durchzuspielen ich habe so ein ganzes
Video ja schon mal hochgeladen verlinken
wir euch hier oben da habe ich Minecraft
gespielt allerdings haben sich Monster
vermehrt wenn ich sie angeguckt habe das
heißt wenn ich den Creeper schlagen
wollte kam automatisch ein zweiter
Creeper ein dritter Creeper und es war
für mich schlussendlich unmöglich
Minecraft durchzuspielen weil es einfach
nicht ging wir haben auch schon die
erste
Höhle es ist doch keine Höhle Mist es
ist eigentlich ein ziemlich cooles Biom
in dem wir hier gespawt sind ich habe
zwar diese Blöcke hier noch nirgendswo
gesehen ach lol das ist
jetzt das ist jetzt
Lava also
Wasser ich Bo ich will es gar nicht
testen allerdings müsste das hier dann
ja eigentlich das verstehe ich halt
nicht warum fängt es dann an zu brennen
das er giibt keinen Sinn aber das müsste
eigentlich dann schwimm oh mein
Gott das
klappt ich habe zwar Lava Animation mit
diesen Funken die hier die ganze Zeit
rumsprühen aber ich kann hier drin
schwimmen als wenn es Wasser wä okay das
brennt aber jetzt trotzdem wieder und
das fügt mir auch keinen Schaden
zu ich muss mich noch ein bisschen an
diese Modifikation gewöhnen wir müssen
so oder so erstmal eine Höhle finden
sieht hier allerdings schon mal ganz gut
aus wir haben auf jeden Fall erstmal
Kohle womit wir uns Fackeln machen
können das ist für die Nacht wichtig wir
brauchen auch ganz ganz wichtig Schafe
damit wir überhaupt erstmal die Nacht
überspringen können ein paar Ressourcen
haben wir auf jeden Fall am Start und
bewegen uns jetzt mal direkt in die
Höhle hier vorne rein ich brauche ja
auch glaube
ich wir haben Schafe also wir hatten
Schafe aber da war auf jeden Fall eins
das heißt da sind vielleicht noch mehr
hört ihr
welche ich nicht aber ich se Höle
perfekt besser jetzt nicht laufen
oh ich wollte schon reinschwimmen aber
B ich habe mir gedacht das Fleisch
besser nicht schmeißen weil vorhin hatte
ich Probleme mit Hunger schmeiß einfach
diesen Block aber das war ein Drittel
von unserem
Bett so gehen wir da unten auf jeden
Fall nicht rein und bewegen uns irgendwo
anders hin wo wir eine Höhle haben und
im besten Falle eventuell auch Schafe
hier sind aber einige große Menge an
Höhlen ehrlich gesagt vorne halt überall
Wasser da dürfen wir halt dann nicht so
wirklich hin die hier schaut aber ein
bisschen riesiger aus tut sie eigentlich
nicht geh einfach noch Wasser auf beiden
Seiten runter also
Lava das ist
doch das kann ja das Video kann ja auch
nicht nur von timelapse leben
olala Freunde wir haben zwar keine Höhle
gefunden allerdings ein Dorf hier vorne
sind h irgendwelche Items ne aber wir
haben zumindest dadurch schon mal ein
Bett am Start und Dorfbewohner auch da
hinten ich baue er mal ganz kurz die
Kohle hier vorne ab wir benötigen um
dann irgendwann halt unser Eisen zu
verbrennen und benutzen zu können ich
versuche mich immer daran zu erinnern
wenn ich Minecraft durch spielen will
wie ich das mit bassti gemacht habe ach
guck mal ein Eisenschwert sogar direkt
und wir haben direkt
Obsidian vier Stück oh mein Gott das
wäre so wichtig wenn wir noch mehr
kriegen für ein Portal weil for real
Freunde wenn ich im Nether bin also in
der Hölle wo überall Lava ist kann ich
ja da überall durchschwimmen und das
möchte ich auf jeden Fall packen okay
hier im Dorf gibt's auf jeden Fall
nichts mehr zu sehen traden mit
Villagern habe ich noch nie so richtig
verstanden deswegen laufe ich einfach
mal weiter ich hoffe halt dass ich
irgendwo so ein halbfertig Portal finde
mit dem ich oh mein Gott könnt ihr euch
noch daran
erinnern von Minecraft mit Luca Staffel
[Musik]
1 das ist so irre schnell oh mein Gott
war so Spaß aber gut okay können
wir mit dem
Boot theoretisch über Lava
fahren
wir laufen weiter durch das schneebiom
haben Schafe die wir allerdings auch gar
nicht mehr töten müssen denn ich habe
das Bett mitgenommen auusen
oha da sind wir
doch oh mein
Gott
Alter was ist das für eine
Höhle das ist obviously Lava aber da
drin könnte ich jetzt schwimmen wir
haben auf jeden Fall ein Eisenschwert
und eigentlich eine ganz okay Ausrüstung
am
Start Problem ist jetzt einfach n wie
ich hier runterkome ne da vorne ist Lava
da könnte ich probieren hinzukommen ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so ganz
ob ich dem Braten hier trauen kann
ja oh mein
Gott
geisteskrank wir kommen der Sache näher
man denkt jetzt wahrscheinlich hey guck
mal hier ist Wasser kann reinspringen
aber es ist ja Lava deswegen müssen wir
wirklich ganz vorsichtig vorgehen hier
vorne können wir easy lang da könnte der
Diamant sogar reinfallen die
[Musik]
Sache ich brauche erstmal
mein ich brauche erstmal vernünftigen
Bruchstein ich probiere jetzt einfach
mal ob es doch mit diesem Bruch ach
lol das geht auch mit dem Krams das
wusste ich natürlich jetzt nicht aber
gut Freunde wir machen uns natürlich gar
keinen Stress gönnen uns hier die Eisens
Zacke da können wir das andere Ding auch
eigentlich mal direkt in Müll schmeißen
und uns direkt den ersten Diamanten
holen der sich hier vorne befindet
meistens sind ja noch welche versteckt
irgendwie ein paar Blöcke dahinter hier
ist das Ganze allerdings nicht der Fall
schauen allerdings trotzdem auch noch
mal hier drum herum obwohl der darf ja
sogar in Lava reinfallen das ist ja
komplett egal hier ist allerdings auch
nichts wen jetzt nur zwei Diamanten
reicht aber auf jeden Fall schon mal für
ein diamantchwert das ist auf jeden Fall
schon mal die halbe Miete um gegen
Monster vernünftig anzugehen
diamantschwert haben wir boah guck mal
wie schön das aussieht das
diamantschwert rechts Wahnsinn ach ein
bisschen Holz wollte ich auf jeden Fall
noch ab wer bist du
denn oh mein Gott au wir haben ja so ein
krasses
Glück wir haben einfach direkt so viele
Diamanten gefunden und brauchen jetzt
nur noch einen s dass wir Obsidian
abbauen können und dementsprechend in
die Hölle gehen können wir haben unter
der Erde hier so genügend Holz am Start
damit wir ausgerüstet sind und können
sogar aufgrund dieser Mods jetzt einfach
hier rein ins in in die Lava und können
halt schauen ob sich unter der Lava auch
noch mal irgendwelche Diamanten
befinden das ist alles nicht mehr normal
oder ich habe drei Diamanten und das
reicht schon für eine diamantpitzhacke
um Obsidian
[Musik]
abzubauen oh mein Gott ich habe mich
hier gerade hochgebaut da unten extra
Blöcke abgebaut soass ich hier Wasser
holen kann was aber eigentlich kein
Wasser oh mein Gott die Dinger knicken
ja um ach du
scheiße und das ist um noch mal euch zu
erinnern Lava das heißt hier darf ich
nicht rein ich habe mich da auf jeden
Fall extra hochgebaut damit ich mir hier
so ein Wasser einal holen kann was
eigentlich ein lavaimer ne warte mal
jetzt muss ich
[Applaus]
umdenken muss ach ich habe es komplett
falsch gemacht ich brauche ja unten
lavaimal den ich über Wasser Schütte und
Lava ist was ach diger das ist so ein
Brand ich muss den Wassereimer
über Lava schütten ich muss jetzt nur
für euch zum Verständnis ich muss wieder
runter weil ich ein Denkfehler hatte
muss einen lavaeimer holen weil das ja
eigentlich Wasser ist und wenn ich dann
an der Oberwelt bin nehme ich mein
Wassereimer was ja Lava ist aber Wasser
wenn ich es über Lava Schütte um dadurch
Obsidian zu
bekommen danke also hiervon brauche ich
ein Eimer das ist jetzt nämlich Lava und
jetzt muss ich das hier drüber irgendwo
an der Oberwelt reinkippen das heißt
eine ganz fixe timelapse wie ich
irgendwie versuchen muss hier
[Musik]
rauszukommen ich bin wieder draußen gibt
euch diesen Himmel das ist so schön mit
dem Shader aber gut wir haben auf jeden
Fall das violette Bett ja abgezogen aus
dem Dorf konnen dementsprechend jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen schön schlafen
gehen das Problem ist dass wir jetzt
einen um wieder keinen Denkfehler zu
haben einen wassersee benötigen weil das
ja Lava wäre und wir dann unseren
lavaeimer der ja Wasser ist darüber
kippen können sollten wir aber glaube
ich hier keine Probleme mit haben wir
sind ja hier schon in Biom wo relativ
viel Wasser ist ist allerdings
zugefroren ne da vorne sollte es klappen
hier wenn ich da jetzt mein lavaeimer
drüber Kippe dann müsste es ja
theoretisch zu Obsidian werden
oder ja guck mal ich bin so schlau hier
sind zwar irgendwelche Grafikfehler aber
es liegt natürlich auch daran dass es
nicht so gewollt ist vom Spiel was ich
hier gerade mache gebt euch das wir
haben vier Obsidian man braucht glaube
ich insgesamt acht für ein Portal also
Obsidian jetzt hier vorne rein und da
und jetzt können wir den ganzen Lachs
auch anzünden wenn wir irgendwo hier
Kies am Rand
[Musik]
haben aber natürlich mal wieder nicht
nur wenige Minuten später ich habe noch
nie so
verzweifelt in Minecraft nach Kies
gesucht etwas länger als nur wenige
Minuten später wir haben Kies und wir
haben gar keinen Stress weil ich ja
nicht ein Arzttermin gleich in 5 Minuten
habe wir haben einen Feuerstein Freunde
das das heißt wir können uns ein Flinten
stetil machen ich benötige dafür
allerdings natürlich auch noch mal eben
kurz gebratenes Eisen deswegen nee das
geht so nicht machen wir so holen uns
ein Eisen übrigens lustige Anekdote ich
habe mal ich wurde mal als ich irgendwie
17 war oder so auf Englisch gefragt ob
ich ein Feuerzeug hätte weil jemand
Raucher war bei uns in der Truppe und
ich habe gedacht das heißt auf Englisch
Flint in stetil und habe ihn dann gesagt
Flint in stetil do und ja keine Ahnung
so lustig nicht aber wir können die
Hölle ich bin gespannt ob das jetzt
funktioniert ne wenn ich jetzt
weg ich kann wirklich hier
schwimmen durch die
Hölle das ist ja so crazy wir müssen
jetzt auf jeden Fall direkt Fortress
finden und
dann Blaze rods
kriegen
dier ich kann einfach hier
runter wie crazy ist
das ich
kann das nürlich UNP ich brauche einfach
nur so eine dumme Festung ich weiß auch
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr so ganz wo
ich
herk na ja sch einfach mal hier
[Musik]
vorne
du hast kein Bett und keinen
aufgeladenen seelenanker oder dein
wiedereinstiegspunkt WD blockiert ich
könnte kotzen diger ich habe ja
geschlafen aber ich habe mein Bett
abgebaut ich dummer Idiot weil ich
dachte wir werden nicht mehr sterben wir
hatten diamantschwert wir hatten
teilrüstung wir hatten eine Diamant
piickaxe wir waren in der Hölle und dann
sterbe ich nicht durch die Wasser laava
Modifikation sondern durch verdammten
picklin